Roxy wrote in you seem to be nonreactive
during interviews on your show no matter
what crazy stuff the guest says but are
there things people say to you in casual
or personal conversations that are sort
of like conversation Stoppers well it's
it's not so much that I'm gonna fly off
the handle in a rage but if I'm having a
casual conversation with something with
someone and they casually refer to
something as [ __ ] or [ __ ] I pretty
instantly say I'm no longer interested
in this conversation so you try to wrap
it up as soon as you can but you can't
really do that no you can't you gotta
I've done it even in situations where it
seems like it might be rude and it might
have been but as soon as you drop that
in I kind of am I mean I just have no
interest in speaking to you whatsoever
if you if you casual and the other day I
actually when I was at a Billy Joel
concert this is not going to reflect
well actually on Bostonians
and we know that there's significant
racism in homophobia and Boston white
being on paper a very progressive City I
was standing there in line waiting to
get in a $12 bottle of water and someone
behind me was also waiting in line and
someone they recognized comes by and
says hey Jim or whatever the guys name
was so nice to see you here yeah so nice
to see you
yeah you know we were gonna go by the
way whit must have been like a co-worker
situation I don't know what and the
woman asks the guy behind me Jim where's
Steve and he goes oh no I'm sorry the
guy asks the woman where's Steve and the
woman says oh he said he had to watch
his kids or something like that okay
goes Oh tell him he's a [ __ ] mm-hmm
immediately I'm like this is just not
anyone I would want to be around just
it's it's just toxic and why do you want
to be around people like this and the
woman seemed to sort of cringe like this
is not really the right way to be
talking about people but when someone
drops that in casual conversation I just
want to walk away yeah no I do
understand that there are those certain
words you just want to not hear or I
guess move beyond whenever you hear them
in conversation I agree I'm more think
about like when you check out something
from like cafe okay and it seems like
the barista just wants to have this
small talk with you oh you don't like
you engage in that or you
try to rush through it um I tend to not
do the small talk thing there is a cafe
I go to with some frequency for meetings
where there's this particular barista
who doesn't recognize me it's not like
they're talking to me because they they
recognize me as a frequent person
because I don't go that often and
they'll always say it's not just like a
hey how's it going and you say fine
whatever little bit or you know that
convention yeah it's how's your day
going today so far and the way it's
asked is more like wow I'm expected to
like really give an answer and I kind of
in flummox because I'm used to that kind
of annoying convention if you say oh I'm
doing well how are you and then the
other other person says oh I'm also
doing well and it communicates nothing
because no one's really telling the
truth but it's just this is what you say
so in a way it's refreshing because
they're genuinely asking how is your day
going today and what makes it a good day
or not a good day so I wouldn't call
that a conversation stopper it might
just be a conversation I'm not prepared
for usually okay well I mean I want to
move beyond just saying good in you when
someone asks you didn't look how are you
yeah but sometimes on the spot it's hard
to express I never write adjectives how
I'm feeling that my move is I'll pretend
to think about it and then say it's
actually a pretty good day I'm doing
pretty well today and it's just a slim
answer it's the same answer but it's a
slightly different wording so it seems
like you really put some thought into it
yeah and unfortunately sometimes you
could be feeling pretty down you can go
higher absolutely and you don't want to
ruin their mood a good way to clear a
room if you need to is you just say
contagious I asked the doctor really
contagious he told me do not go out in
public that's a way to end everybody's
conversation and clear a room if you
find yourself needing to and I know
often you need to you find yourself
needing to clear a room I mean hey if
there's a lot of people in that
restaurant or wherever you're at you
want to get your food as quickly as you
can yeah that's the right move if you
want to clear out a restaurant you
talked about a mouse or a rat believe me
that gets people very very nervous and
then they leave
don't use [ __ ] or [ __ ] come on it's
it's 2017 folks let's talk about what's
on the bonus show today do we know
what's on the bonus show today I am NOT
going to tell you what's on the bonus
show today because I'm out of time but
believe me folks it's a fantastic bonus
show